Tariel: Hello! My name is Tario. I will use windows. 11 OS speech, recognition, call voice access for our terminal navigation and chrome as my browser. My task today is to log in and open it. Course, call introduction to accessibility scroll and continue learning. complete the lesson click, complete the last activity, and view my badge. V. when you see the pop up
Tariel: after I open up a new page, call accessibility champions find my badge.
Tariel: the download badge button and the share button option.
Tariel: I will not select them. I would just locate them.
Tariel: I will use click show numbers. Miles grid move down
Tariel: scroll and dictation commands to
Tariel: complete this complete the test. I was given today also. with the dictations command. If the detection don't work, I have to use a another command, call show keyboard, and then I will say the numbers to type in, and Mary manually.
Tariel: So now I'm gonna start my task before I start my task. I can't talk.
Tariel: Why is in progress? I gotta literally say voice,
Tariel: to go to sleep and wake up, for you know.
Tariel: for me to tell you how I feel about it issues. If there any issues or what I like about it. So I'm gonna start now.
Tariel: Voice access. Wake up.
Tariel: press. Enter.
Tariel: Hmm!
Tariel: Start scrolling down
Tariel: so numbers
Tariel: like 30.
Tariel: So that call
Tariel: back space.
Tariel: So keyboard
Tariel: like 25.
Tariel: Click, 11,
Tariel: played 14,
Tariel: click, fitting. click, fitting state. 3. Take 10, click, 5,
Tariel: click, 16,
Tariel: click, 37,
Tariel: click, 2
Tariel: high keyboard
Tariel: press, enter.
Tariel: move down. 6.
Tariel: Take introduction to accessibility.
Tariel: Click, introduction to the accessibility form.
Tariel: press, answer.
Tariel: mouse, click.
Tariel: start scrolling down.
Tariel: scroll up.
Tariel: moved out for
Tariel: move down to
Tariel: voice access, sleep.
Tariel: So when I was kept saying, they click sustainability, introduction, accessibility of scorn, they kept saying, swarm and score and stuff like that. So I used the mouse click to
Tariel: go to the next page. So now I'm use click, continue learning to keep going through the to the lesson.
Voice, access, sleep.
Tariel: I mean voice that says, Wake up.
Tariel: voice, access, wake up!
Tariel: Click! Continue learning.
Tariel: Start scrolling down.
Tariel: move up, 6,
Tariel: move up, 8,
Tariel: move down, 12,
Tariel: move up. move up, 12,
Tariel: move down for
Tariel: moved out. 8
Tariel: click, finish.
Tariel: moved out for
Tariel: move, down, for
Tariel: click, view badges
Tariel: start scrolling down.
Tariel: start scrolling up
Tariel: voice access leak
Tariel: calls.
Tariel: apology for the pause. I I I had to have clarification on
Tariel: on my activity for that. But now I'm keep on going with the test right now. Everything look good.
Tariel: yeah, right now. Everything. You look good. I'm scroll up and down first. just to make sure you know
Tariel: all this all, and then I'm scored back up and locate the the download badge and
Tariel: the share, badge, option.
Tariel: voice access, wake up.
Tariel: start scrolling down.
Tariel: move up for
Tariel: start scrolling up.
Tariel: stop
Tariel: voice, access, sleep.
Tariel: Okay. Right here. I like everything I may have to able to use my
Tariel: my navigation to move around and everything scroll up to locate things, and I see on the right hand side with directly on the level one, the top
Tariel: box where you see the download badge on your right hand, side in it by. So it's right in your face. She was able to get to it and everything. So I like that.
Tariel: overall through this text everything looked good, everything worked. I'm use mouse grid
Tariel: because I haven't used my degree yet and just to see if it's gonna move to the numbers and everything, and I'll be you show link show numbers. One more time, just to make sure it works on here.
Tariel: Voice access. Wake up.
Tariel: mouse greed
Tariel: 5
Tariel: click
Tariel: website. So numbers
Tariel: mouse, click.
Tariel: plate.
Tariel: scroll up.
Tariel: start scrolling up.
Tariel: stop. show, numbers.
Tariel: voice, access, sleep.
Tariel: So all in all, everything look good. Everything works for me. I like that. You you able to get to stuff fast and easy, as you see on your right hand side, like I said to download badge. But and I'll show link button is right there. and overall. I didn't. I haven't had any issues but the issue of my
Tariel: voice my terminal navigation was saying different words to the same word as form, and it says other stuff like score. And what have you?
Tariel: But I hope you find this video helpful thanks for listening.